what's uh the origin of of uh
the suspender wearing Batman what how
did you come to do what you do like what
we talked about where you are and how
your mind works but how did it start
I've kind of always been interested in
fraud or or at least I saw fraud early
on and I was just like curious about
what is this I didn't know what I was
really looking at so basically my mom
got cancer when I was in high school and
it was pretty traumatic I mean she's
fine she had thyroid cancer which is I
we didn't know it at the time it's like
Cancer's cancer but it's fairly easily
treatable with surgery uh it's one of
the better you know survivable ones and
I just watched her get like bombarded
with all these like phony Health scams
of you know just like colloidal silver
you know all these different like
remedies and she was very into you know
all the different ways that she might
treat her cancer obviously surgery is
very daunting and you know I was just
confused I was like why are we doing so
many different remedies that all seem a
very dubious health value
later I'd find out that these are like
all grifters I mean they take advantage
of free speech in America to like
advertise their products as you know
life-saving Miracles whatever when
they're of course not
um eventually she got the surgery thank
God but I know people in my life who
their parents passed away because
because they didn't have the surgery
they instead
took the alternative option I know like
I don't want to go into specifics
because I don't want to mention their
specific like case but their uh family
member went to Mexico for some alternate
treatment health treatment instead of
getting an easy surgery and they died
and so it's like
I realized you know where is the outrage
about this where is the who covers this
stuff and I realized well not many
people do then I went to college I was
getting a chemical engineering degree
and all my friends were like telling me
you know hey you should come to this
meeting you know we don't need this like
you're doing this engineering stuff
that's great you're going to make like
70k a year but don't you want to get
like rich now like why wait till you're
60 years old to retire like you can be
rich now Lex so
I'd go show up to a hotel and there'd be
an MLM like multi-level marketing you
know pitch for uh Amway or whatever it
was that day and
I was once again fascinated I didn't
know what I was looking at but I was
like what is this weird game we're all
playing where we sit in this room we're
looking at the speaker who says he's so
successful right but why is he taking a
Friday or a Saturday to do this you know
pitch at night and they're gonna telling
me I'm going to be financially free but
they're working on their Saturday and
Sunday and so it's like how financially
free are they so just like confused I
was like you know none of my friends
were Rich they all said they were going
to be rich no one ever seemed to get
rich and so I was sort of baffled by
what I was looking at later I graduate I
had no interest in doing engineering
which we can kind of get into but I want
to do something in media
um and I started covering a variety of
topics but eventually I sort of
Revisited this interest in fraud and I
started talking about these kind of get
rich quick grifters that were online
sort of the the Tai Lopez variety you
know 67 steps or you know whatever like
five steps to get rich five coins to
five million you know these get rich
quick schemes that a lot of people were
interested in no one seemed to get rich
once again except for the people at the
tippity tippity top selling the get rich
quick thing and I was like fascinated by
the structure of it I was like does
nobody see what this is like does nobody
get it so I started making a series of
videos on that and the response was like
palpable I mean it was like I've made a
lot of stuff before that I had made
stuff that got a million views I'd had
like some marginal success but the
response of like the emails that came in
the I could tell this work even though
it had far less views at the time was
having a different level of impact
that's what I was really interested in
one of my problems with engineering was
from my standpoint I did chemical
engineering at Texas A M
and like I was like is my future just
going to be in a chemical plant
improving some process by two percent
and it's like my gift to the world like
I just I didn't see the hard impact and
that maybe that's a lack of imagination
because chemicals matter but I needed I
wanted to see an impact in the world and
so when like I did start doing this
fraud stuff exposing fraud I like
clicked in my brain I was like whoa this
is kind of doing what I want to do and
so I started posting videos at first it
really focused on like get rich quick
scheme grifty advertising which I think
is super predatory and we can go into
why but um it eventually graduated to
crypto and
it's snowballed I guess because now
we're talking to Sam magnet freed